[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
getting down
[Music]
foreign
when you start talking and tell me what
you want
fifty thousand dollars
how you figure that 35 for the pound of
Matthew stole and another 15 from my
partner's pain and suffering
oh yeah
I remember that little [__]
so you must be Daddy
okay
let me get this straight
I steal your dope
all right
out of your new boy
bring me more men
whoa that's a brilliant plan is it
really
you got one part of that wrong
that's
is not math
[Applause]
hey [__] nuts I want to find out
Karma
there you go balls
give me that
all right all right
I'll give you your money
at Crystal
sure
partner brought me
it's sold faster than ten dollar ass and
TJ
let's say you bring me
another pound next week
money up front
take it easy Theo
I will feed you Aid first that's the
deal
what
[Music]
oh I get it
oh yeah greedy old bastard
tell you how it's worth it
you feed them huh you put them in a
really nice Crib in the country and yet
they got to steal the food off your
plate
you better eat every bite of that
oh
God
see yo
foreign
[Music]
ER where are you going
to
Heaven is back right pretty big one
what's the matter straighter you act
like you never saw a severed human head
on a Taurus before
no way
hey welcome to
[Applause]
um
foreign
the best legal representation ever but
no deals with the DEA
all right Badger will not identify
anyone to anybody if he does
you're dead
why don't you just kill badger
I mean follow me guys but mosquitoes
buzzing around you bites you on the ass
you don't go gun it for the mosquitoes
attorney you could go grab a fly swatter
so to speak
I mean all due respect do I have to
spell this out for you
we're not killing Badger yo then you got
real problems okay because the DEA is
going to come down on your boy like a
proverbial ton of bricks I mean I I
don't think I'm going out on a limb here
but hey he's not gonna like prison he's
gonna sing like Celine Dion regardless
of what you do to me
Mr Mayhew
recognize your cough take that mask off
you don't get some air one
take it easy breathe in breathe out all
right I'm gonna stand up all right
because I got bad knees
that's better
okay now now I'm listening to three of
us I'm gonna work this out yeah how
first things first you're gonna put a
dollar in my pocket both of these
you want attorney client privilege don't
you so that everything you say is
strictly between us
I mean it put a dollar in my pocket come
on make it official
come on do it
that's it come on
just a dollar what
all right now you ski bomb come on give
it the dollar
come on be smart what
I got some five I'll take a five come on
already come on
cool
okay you're now both officially
represented by Saul Goodman and
Associates your secrets are safe with me
under threat of disbarment all right
take the ski mask off I feel like I'm
talking to the Weather Underground here
just do it
okay so if a prison shanky is completely
off the table
and we're sure of that
no sinking
right right
and the way I see it is
somebody's going to prison
it's just a matter of who
[Music]
Jesse
wake up Jesse wake up
foreign
[Music]
why are you doing this why are you even
thinking this way
is it to punish me
I am not punishing you while this is
punitive is what this is
we are happily married
I am happily married I am happy
richest
I love you
Skyler
and I would do anything
for you
would you even
consider I mean Jesus
you come in here and you wave these
papers in my face when there's a whole
other entire side to this thing there's
your side and there's my side and you
haven't heard my side yet you haven't
heard any of it at all you're a drug
dealer
no what what how
how else could you possibly make that
kind of money
marijuana
that Pinkman kid
no
oh my God what
cocaine
methamphetamine
but I'm
I'm a manufacturer I'm not a dealer
oh
per se I it it doesn't mean no Skyler
this is no there are a lot of angles to
this okay it's complicated all right so
please please let's let's just sit back
down and we'll talk it through
I'm gonna make you a deal Walt
I won't tell Hank
children
or anybody else nobody will hear it from
me
but only if you grant me this divorce
and stay out of our Lives I mean it
now let me bow out of here before I
throw up
so how was your day
good
thanks a lot I hope you don't mind I
divide it lowest stay for dinner tonight
you know as a thank you for driving
Walter Jr to school for us
kind of absent
Louis really pitched in
um
look I just want to say that I
I feel good about our talk this morning
and I'm very eager to hear what you're
thinking about
about what we talked about
you know whenever you're ready then of
course
honesty
is good don't you think
I [__] Ted
boys dinner
okay
Louis oh yes please all right
I want to be close to eat your salad
okay
I'll be like salad but
it's good for you thanks Charlie thank
you
let me understand this
you're turning down one and a half
million dollars I'm not turning down the
money
I am turning down you
get it
I want nothing to do with you
ever since I met you
everything I have ever cared about
is gone
ruins turned to [__]
instead ever since I hooked up with the
great Heisenberg
I have never been more alone
I have nothing
no one
all right it's all gone get it
no
no no why
why would you
get it
what do you even care as long as you get
what you want
right
you don't give a [__]
about me
you said I was no good
I'm nothing
why would you want me huh
you said my mat is inferior right
right hey you said Mike cook was garbage
it's screw you man
screw you
your math is good Jesse
as good as mine
[Music]
[Applause]
leave me alone
[Music]
[Applause]
hi
how can I help you
[Applause]
um
take whatever you want
I have money
I got a lot of money
um
please don't do this
you don't you
you don't have to do this
what was I thinking
well to please let's both of us stop
trying to justify this whole thing and
admit you're in danger
who is it you think you see
do you know how much I make a year I
mean even if I told you you wouldn't
believe it
do you know what would happen if I
suddenly decided to stop going into work
a business big enough that it could be
listed on the NASDAQ goes Belly Up
ceases to exist without me no you
clearly don't know who you're talking to
so let me clue you in I am not in danger
Skyler I am the danger a guy opens his
door and gets shot and you think that of
me no
I am the one who knocks
well what was the problem why'd you have
to kill him watch the crosstalk please
maybe it's not the details that matter
right
how do you feel about what you did Jesse
I don't know
who cares how you feel
what kind of a person kills a dog for no
reason Colleen you put an ad in the
paper you drop them off at a shower you
just sit there and talk about killing a
helplessness
we're not here to sin in judgment
why not
why not maybe maybe she's right
you know maybe I should have put it in
the paper maybe I should have done
something different
the thing is
if you just do stuff and nothing happens
what's it all mean
what's the point
oh right this this whole thing is about
self-acceptance
kicking the hell out of yourself doesn't
give meaning to anything so I should
stop
judging
and accept to start
so no matter what I do
array for me because I'm a great guy
it's all good
no matter how many dogs I kill I just do
an inventory
and accept
I mean you back your truck over your own
kid and you like accept
what a load of crap hey Jessie I know
you're in pain you know what
why I'm here in the first place
is to sell your meth
you're nothing to me but customers
I made you my [__]
you okay with that
huh
you accept
about time
[Music]
thank you
personalized
I love it
down here
what what did that phone call mean
[Music]
where's the rest
the money Skyler where is the rest
I gave it to Ted
I'm
I had to
for us for the family I swear to gave
our money to panic
what please please just hear me out
please
[Music]
laughs
hi you've reached the white family
please leave a message
Skyler
it's happening again the DEA called they
got some temperament informant that
the cartel they want to kill Hank
right now to guard us come on
Marie I'm here
I'm here
tell me exactly what happened
foreign
no man at all
a crippled little rata
what a reputation to leave behind
is that how you want to be remembered
last chance to look at me actor
[Music]
[Applause]
George
[Music]
[Applause]
my partner tells me that your crew
switched to a P2P cook because of our
success
you dye your meth with food coloring to
make it look like mine you already ate
my product at every turn
but now
you have the opportunity to sell it
yourself
I need you to listen to me we're not
going to give up this deal to be your
Aaron boys do you understand me
for what
watch a bunch of junkies get a better
High a better High
means customers pay more
they are purity means a greater yield
that's 130 million dollars of profit
that isn't being pissed away by some
substandard cook
Now you listen to me
we've got the greatest meth cook in them
I know the two
greatest meth Cooks in America right
here and with our skills
you'll earn more from that 35 percent
than you ever would on your own yeah
so you say just wondering why we're so
lucky
why cut us in Mike is retiring from our
crew so his share of the partnership is
available if
you can handle his end
distribution
and if you give him five million dollars
of the 15 million that you brought today
just think of it as a finder's fee for
bringing us together
we have 40 pounds of product ready to
ship
ready to go
are you ready
who the hell are you
you know
you all know exactly who I am
say my name
do what oh I don't have a damn clue who
the hell you are
I'm the cook
I'm the man who killed Gus Fring
[__]
cartel girlfriend
you sure
that's right
now
say my name
you're goddamn right
to ww my star my perfect silence
WWE
let me know you figure that out
Woodrow Wilson
Willy Wonka
Walter White
you got me
stop
turn around
place your fingers behind your head
I walk backwards to me
get on your knees
I just like my Barrel photo huh
took it in the backyard by the barbecue
grill
you know
where we used to cook out with the
family
tell me here thought the dirt might not
match but me I bet you greedy ass should
be so worked up about the prospect of
losing your cash that you wouldn't catch
it
looks like I was right
he's clean
yo I remember this place
the very first place we cooked like ever
it is
n't it
hey uh say uh you save us a busy work
well point out the spot where you buried
your money
no
no matter
I got a search team out here we'll find
it
agent Gomez should we flip a coin for
the honors no way man it's all yours
Walter White
you have the right to remain silent
anything you say can and will be used
against you in a court of law you have
the right to speak to an attorney and
have an attorney president during any
questioning if you cannot afford an
attorney one will be provided for you at
the government's expense do you
understand these rights as I've just
recited them to you
Howard
get over here get over here
put him in a car come on get in the car
hurry up yeah
get in the car kid just come on
sorry man just no scenario where this
guy lives no no listen hi money I had
money
it's very down here
it's
80 million dollars
80.
million
so that's what got this party started
huh
but this money ears won't do me much
good in prison
you could do anything
future that you want
Jack 80
million
and all you've got to do
is let him go
that's a hell of an offer
what do you think Fred
would you take that deal
it's Hank
his name is Hank
how about it Hank
should I let you go
my name is asak Schroeder
and you can go [__] yourself
Hank
listen to me
you got a feeling you gotta tell him now
that we can work this out please please
what
you want me to beg
you're the smartest guy I ever met
you're too stupid to see
he made up his mind 10 minutes ago
do what you're gonna do
foreign
[Music]
get you waiting there too long my love
I didn't know you think that I forget
all right regret
a special love I had for you
[Music]
did you really think I do it wrong
oh
just realized
[Music]
I will show
special love I have for you
[Music]